in a game with some of the most iconic
character designs of all time what does
it take to truly stand out in League of
Legends every new Champion changes the
game giving players the tools to
redefine how it's played
but sometimes the more distinctive a
playstyle the more frustrating it is to
play against and a few characters are
more frustrating than you me
you smell tasty Yumi is the answer to a
very specific question what if your
support if played correctly could never
be touched I am not kidding like when I
say that if they removed Yumi from the
game it would be a better game
foreign
before we get into this I want to thank
the sponsor of the video Opera GX we
tried out their gaming browser and
honestly it's made me realize just how
bad some of the other browsers I've been
using actually are now have you ever
tried to quit League of Legends but
found yourself going back to it like an
X whose number you really should delete
while your browser is a bit like that
too we continue to struggle with bad
browsers because we're familiar with
them but there is another way Opera GX
if Chrome or Firefox are the X's that
make you feel like you're heading
backwards in life Opera GX is the new
hot fresh person you just met at a bar
or a Barren Lobby and guess what you
guys just click the browser is built
specifically for gamers it has custom
themes twitch and Discord Integrations
pin boards a free VPN and the ability to
send any content to yourself on all of
your devices using my flow Meanwhile
your old browser still thinks bookmarks
are a game changer and complains when
you open more than 10 tabs it's an
absolute no-brainer guys dump your old
browser and see how well opera GX treats
you consider this me giving you its
phone number okay so Yumi is the single
most hated champion in League of Legends
but you wouldn't know that based on how
people reacted when she first came out
otherwise put a smile on my face she is
so cute man see Yumi was added to the
game on May 14 2019 as Champion number
144 and while she was adorable she was
kind of terrible wait this Champion's
useless she's gonna be probably a weak
laner probably gonna be like gotta be
careful of like getting ganked Yumi
launched with an absolutely abysmal win
rate forcing Ryan to buff the champion
the day after her release but there
still wasn't a lot of optimism around
her viability do you find Yumi
frustrating at all to play against I
have never lost again Jimmy so I'm not
worried Yumi was fundamentally unlike
anything League fans had ever seen at
her core Yumi is an enchanter support
who stays away from the ACT while
buffing and protecting her allies but
what makes her different from basically
every other champion in the game is her
W skill you and me which lets her attach
to an ally and become untargetable then
she can use her abilities to heal them
while also dealing some damage to the
enemy team it was a completely new way
to play the game Yumi players couldn't
be attacked and they didn't even have to
move at first her unique playstyle gave
the average player some trouble but Pros
were quick to adapt and discovered some
truly busted strats wait a minute
[Applause]
why is this is
yeah not even gonna be contested by Tony
forces they can't because they're
getting they're getting worse yeah I'll
tie this Duo oh my God I've seen this in
three run away
Reckless is Unstoppable this is the raw
decision-making power a pillow tank but
whenever he tries to make a bad choice
Reckless can say no it's an Unstoppable
bot Lane Duo teams like fanatic
pioneering strategies that created
absolutely unkillable and unfun bot
Lanes like Garen Yumi something no one
was all that excited to see at Worlds a
few months later what patch is it what
camp is it what kind of Mind Games is
this
wait which is the better non-interactive
bot Lane it got to the point where
people complain Yumi ruined the
tournament and not because she was
oppressive but because the sort of
gameplay she enabled just wasn't fun to
watch so the change is Riot made in June
2019 had a specific goal in mind they
wanted Yumi players to have to hop out
of an ally and ought to attack an enemy
in order to get the passive shield and
share it with her teammate at least that
way someone could hit her sometimes but
the pros quickly discovered other things
that made Yumi unique also made her one
of the most infuriating champions in the
game the healing and shielding weren't
the issue the problem was that she was
untargetable while doing them so there
really wasn't any counter play fine
sproxa and now they're gonna try and get
out of here yeah he's got Hillary saying
kind of get him with him yeah picks up
the cue the resident's trying to bring
them back as cliff goes golden now Khan
is gonna close the gap he's chasing
after proxa once more as the Zoomies are
helping speed this rexai away league
players didn't like how strong Yumi was
and how difficult it was to interact
with her play style it got so bad that
people started calling for Riot to
delete the champion in response to Fan
outcry Riot gutted Yumi and literally
had to publish an article defending her
existence to the player base but people
still wanted to remove her from the game
why well first off playing Yumi or
playing alongside her requires
coordination and cooperation and I
probably don't need to tell you that
these aren't exact Hallmarks of the
League of Legends matchmaking experience
riots changes didn't really address the
issue of Yumi being fundamentally unfun
both to play with and against still Yumi
was competitively viable all the way
until season 10 but after another round
of Nerfs in 2021 her pick rate basically
evaporated that was probably for the
best because Yumi was not well liked
please delete Yumi from the game please
please but then at World 2021 the cat
came back with an incredible 96.4 pick
and ban rate Yumi was a big factor at
Worlds and she got her first world skin
thanks to edg's Mako patterned after his
own pet cat Yumi got some Nerfs early in
the year but Buffs to her base stats in
may even with some accompanying ability
nurse meant that she was well and truly
back for summer once the most annoying
Champion they ever play against Yumi
Yumi needs to be gone that's a solid one
I was thinking about this one I think
is just so annoying and I don't think it
should be allowed that she has to press
this little buttons in the game and
still win be like a minimum amount of
button presses that Yumi is for sure
under you can lose a line with it by 10
times but if someone from your like team
is fat whatever like Champion it is you
can just sit on him and you'll just
carry the game right and then Roy did
something nobody wanted after some more
attempts to Nerf the cat they buffed her
damage before worlds turning Yumi into
exactly the sort of monster everyone had
always dreaded she would become Yumi was
oppressive at Worlds at one point Caster
medic pointed out that she was the most
gold efficient damage dealer in the
tournament all while being for the most
part untargetable when she did get
through the draft of Worlds Yumi pretty
much won some games all by herself
immediate flash there from here to start
this one up at the final is fantastic
a spawn to be picked up for Jackie love
of all people and they're not done there
to deny it and the double and Jackie
talking myself speaking of the combo a
lot of damage here great Encore is going
to land there pretty and Target Miss
just tanking them up flash out
immediately though as hope dive Dives
forward back at you you can't take all
of those minions
[Applause]
he's got his Yumi locked and loaded the
ignite on to wonder that tree is going
down it got so bad that some of the
loudest cheers at the event were for
when she wasn't being played seemed to
be something the teams had figured out
about Rogue in between week one and week
two fans cheering as Yumi is banned out
if Riot hoped that the fan base would
eventually come around on Yumi it's
tough to imagine this world's patch
brought the devs any closer to that goal
Yumi has become a major talking point at
the most important Tournament of the
year and for all the wrong reasons and
it seems inevitable that the tiny
magical cat is destined for some future
adjustments but what should those be why
is Yumi so difficult for Riot to balance
and even if her win rate isn't too high
why is it that everyone seems to hate
playing with her or against her so much
well for one she's an enchanter who can
ignore one of the role's biggest
weaknesses being killed through Focus
fire backline access doesn't matter if
you can't even hit her that means she is
reliable safe and hard to counter you
can try to focus down the Allies she's
attached to but she's actually good at
preventing that and if all else fails
she can often bail onto the next Ally
many champions synergize with her so
well that just can die Perma Hill so
much damage CeCe can die how do you play
against it so I think this champ has a
flaw design and I think it should be
removed or banned Ryan's June 2019
change to her Shield was an attempt to
increase yumi's vulnerability but she's
still incredibly safe like it takes out
some of the layers of gameplay of like
you know positioning picking people off
like like all this stuff is it's just I
think her gameplay is really lame I
think it's like Giga unfun to play
against and either yeah she's useless
because her team is useless or she's gig
out P monstrophy monster zombie because
she cannot be killed and she's just
going as a little parasite on top of a
different Champion that is fed and
frankly many in the competitive scene
just want her removed from the game
altogether I am not kidding like when I
say that if they removed Yumi from the
game it would be a better game if Ryan
admits they messed up with come Tech
great and removes it why can't they do
the same with Yumi because they didn't
mess up with you on that Victor so Yumi
is a very healthy Champion that creates
a new unique play style that allows
players to really engage both with their
teammates and their opponents and create
an extremely
so where does that leave us well it's
hard to imagine Riot actually removing
Yumi from the game at this point given
their stubborn defense of the lazy
kitten and balance is only one aspect of
this discussion because as doublelift
pointed out even if her win rate was
balanced that doesn't mean that Yumi is
something that people want in the game
you know I think the one the one like
Counterpoint that I want to address with
that thing is like oh well then how come
you be's win rate is always so low Yumi
is perfectly balanced because her win
rate is usually pretty low she's under
50. you know to that I just say like if
you nerfed that Champions numbers low
enough then she will have a low one rate
but that still doesn't make a good
design Brian's defense of Yumi is that
she represents entered a unique play
style which is still true but if that's
the only positive thing we can say while
she's terrorized the player base for
over three years how exactly is this
Champion making League better or more
interesting imagine if there was a
champion where when you lock it in it
has a there's a coin flips at the
beginning of the game and then one Nexus
explodes well it's probably balanced
because it's completely Fair both teams
have an equal chance of picking the
champion and both teams have an equal
chance of winning the game it's a
perfect 50 win rate the design is still
dog it's not fun it's not
interactive like that's basically you me
on the other end of the spectrum and if
it isn't making the game better then why
the hell hasn't Yumi been deleted yet
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification Bell for Unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our Twitter Instagram
Facebook and Tech talk
[Music]